a lot of people are interested in brain
training and cognitive development will
tend to focus on specific aspects things
like concentrations verbal fluency
memory all that stuff is cool but to me
it's not as interesting as things like
creativity insights or the ability to
see the world in ways that other people
don't someone who was famously brilliant
at this was Albert Einstein and what's
awesome in a very morbid science fiction
kind of way is that researchers have
been able to look at our own brain to
see what made him tick what made him
fake the way he did and by extrapolating
from that information it's possible that
we can come up with ways to train
ourselves to think a little bit more
like Einstein
[Music]
so on theory about what makes somebody
intelligent is that it has to do with
global brain connectivity as the name
suggests this is the notion that you
have more connectivity between different
areas in the brain so your brain is
separated into different regions and the
best of these are connected to one
another so the theory goes the better
you should be able to bring together
information from disparate areas
different senses different modes of
thinking to come up with something
original and unique it promotes synergy
one to some theories you can only ever
have intelligence and specific domains
Gardner's theory of multiple
intelligences is along these lines
saying that you can be a genius in
movement or a genius in music or math or
English Lit unlikely to be a genius in
all of those things so by looking at
general brain connectivity you can look
at more generalized intelligence and
perhaps also things like creativity and
you know what makes a polymath but
Einstein showed evidence of both these
different types of intelligence because
he had specific regions of his brain
dedicated to logic maps and spatial
intelligence but he also showed greater
synergy between those areas and also
more connectivity throughout the brain
and in particular he had a lot of
connectivity between his visual spatial
areas and his mathematical reasoning
areas which makes a lot of sense
regarding thought about physics a lot so
in particular
Einstein had and especially
well-developed sets of inferior parietal
lobes these are to do with spatial
reasoning but they're also part of the
Association cortex the association
cortex is a network of brain regions
that regulate this synergy between
different parts of the brain so this is
a part of the brain that literally takes
your visual information and looks at how
that relates to other information coming
from other parts of your brain that that
literally confirms or appears to confirm
that theory and it also Stickley
interesting because if we look at on
Stein's
own words his description of how he came
up with some of his ideas then he seems
to suggest himself that he would
visualize them and then he would
intuitively understand them so when he
was thinking about traveling at the
speed of light
she visualized doing you imagine what
that would be like and then he just knew
what that meant and how that pertains to
reality you know as you do okay so he
said if I see a beam of light with a
velocity C velocity of light in vacuum I
should observe a beam of light of an
electromagnetic field at rest so
spatially oscillating
there seems to be no such thing however
neither on the basis of experience nor
according to Maxwell's equations from
the very beginning it appeared to me
intuitively clear that judged from the
standpoint of such an observer
everything would have to happen
according to the same laws as one
observer whose relative to the earth was
at rest so how should the first observer
know we'll be able to determine that he
is in a state of fast uniform motion one
sees in this paradox the germ of the
special relativity theory it already
contained Einsteins inferior parietal
lobes weren't just larger and more
developed there they're also oddly
shaped most of us have got a cleavage a
fissure between the two hemispheres in
this brain region called the Sylvian
fissure Einstein so V efficient Sylvian
fissure with a different shape and it's
less pronounced meaning that he could
communicate between the two sides more
efficiently and he also had a thicker
corpus callosum this would have allowed
both hemispheres of the brain all the
regions to communicate more readily the
corpus callosum is a network of nerves a
kind of band of nerves that literally
goes from one side of the brain for the
other this is how you transfer
information from one side to the other
Einstein's word sticker and this allowed
once again more whole grains kind of
thinking and what's also interesting
those indices that some of Armstrong's
other brain areas suffered as a result
of this famously he wasn't as good with
words he didn't learn to speak until he
was three and likewise there were rumors
that he was dyslexic or at least
somewhat less able and it came to
spelling etc this follows from what we
know about brain plasticity one area
grows as you use it more other areas
shrink as you don't use them so much so
that's all very interesting but what I
really want to know is how we can apply
this to our own lives and think more
like Einstein theoretically well first
of all if you want to think more
creatively and if you want to use more
whole brain thinking you need to relax
there's a theory that all ideas are
essentially not new but combinations of
old ideas so it's come with a new idea
we need to think of two different things
combine it in a unique way to create
something original this is one
explanation for why global brain
connectivity would help you to come up
with more novel ideas because you're
able to take two different neurons the
represents different thoughts different
memories and then combine them as your
brain is spreading out and looking at
all these different areas of your brain
in order to achieve that you want to use
what's called the default mode network
this is a network of brain regions
though responsible for daydreaming
forward planning and coming up with
unique ideas this kicks in whenever we
engaged in a kind of mundane task for
instance if we go for a walk and find
self daydreaming then don't know how he
got to the destination that's because
your default mode network has kicked in
Einstein famously worked in a patent
office so the idea here is that he was
busy just stamping his patents letting
his body do the work really whilst his
brain was up in a way thinking of all
the unique and interesting ideas what
you mustn't do if you want to be
creative is to be highly focused and
stressed but you're working towards a
goal if you're scared or if you're just
really trying to get work done to
deadlines then you enter the
fight-or-flight State which is a
complete opposite of the default mode
Network here your brain becomes far more
honed and focus on specific brain area
which pertains to what you're doing when
you're running away from a line you
don't to be daydreaming about what would
it be like to be traveling at the speed
of light you want to be just focused on
dodging things and running and not
looking back so when you are stressed
when you're working with deadlines when
you're under pressure your brain becomes
more focused and narrow and you become
less creative when you relax and allow
your thoughts just wonder then you can
come up with creative new ideas and not
so you need to work in a pacing office
but what I am saying is that maybe go
from a walk and schedule some time into
your routine to just let your mind
wander walking is great for this just
don't walk into traffic what did they
really
yeah I was doing this just now is
relaxing reaching a Burger King when you
eat by the way you produce serotonin
which is a feel-good hormone and this
converts the melatonin a relaxation
hormone the brain goes into that same
relaxed state and I thought hey why
don't the King and McDonald's be like a
crossover because you know when superior
to a crossover that's like a massive
thing if max Donald's and Burger King
did a crossover that would be like great
marketing I definitely go to McDonald's
to try out the you know milk whopper
when you see that's the kind of idea you
have when you're relaxing waste of those
I'm probably not going to pitch it to
either of them and another thing we can
do maybe is to try and develop our
brains to become more like Weinstein
structurally brain plasticity describes
the ability of our brain to growth and
to change shape as we use it just like
you can train muscles to get bigger by
using them so you can change different
areas of your brain to get bigger by
using them so you could even say so it's
likely that Einstein's inferior parietal
lobes and other brain areas were bigger
but could use them more because he was
thinking about math and physics those
parts of the brain got larger because he
wasn't so interested in writing novels
those parts of the brain atrophy so in
theory just by practicing using those
brain areas you could maybe make them
larger and thus take a little bit more
like Einstein so one thing you can do
and something I'm quite interested in
I've written a blog post on it in the
past is train your ability to visualize
this is a useful skill you know the
ability to bring something to start
release in front of your mind's eye and
to imagine it to rotate it and to then
manipulate it with your mind this is a
skill that comes in handy in all kinds
of different areas and it's something
that you can practice anywhere you are
so if you want to improve your spatial
awareness and your visualization skills
that might be one way of doing it
computer games might also be useful for
developing spatial awareness and some
studies do suggest that if you want to
increase the connectivity between the
two hemispheres of your brain then one
tried you tested where you can do this
is by training ambidexterity
studies have shown that ambidextrous
people have thicker corpus callosum
close eye closes corpus callosum ZZZ and
distance because of course they're using
with two different hemispheres of their
brain more when they're writing and
doing other things
once again I've made posts on this and
videos on this you can train your
ambidexterity in a number of ways
largely by just using your left hand
more to write and do other things like
that and if you want to promote synergy
between your different brain regions
then another thing to do is to practice
using your visual intelligence alongside
your auditory cortex so for instance
when you're looking around to be more
mindful of where the sounds are coming
from and what image belongs to what
sound sounds like Munson it can check my
video on training your senses like
daredevil f6 about this in a bit more
detail and explain how your senses are
more powerful when use them in unison to
see more mindful of the complete
sentence picture can help you to combine
those different senses in your mind and
interestingly meditation has also been
shown to increase general brain
connectivity and to even boost the
amount of gray matter you have an
important region that's another thing
you can use to strengthen your brain and
develop it and of course practicing Maps
could also be useful and whilst you're
training these different skills you also
want to improve your brain plasticity
you can actually increase how plastic
your brain is and how malleable it is at
any given time certain supplements and
nutrients can do this with magnesium
three and eight can increase plasticity
according to some studies as can the
lion's mane mushroom or valproate
although don't recommend that latter one
more interesting though is simply the
fact that when you're learning your
brain becomes awash with chemicals like
BDNF brain-derived neurotrophic factor
nerve growth factor dopamine
all of which promotes further brain
plasticity and this is why our brains of
so classic of children you see a lot of
people think that children are so great
at learning things picking up languages
learn to walk etcetera because of some
kind of genetic switch that turns off
when they reach a certain age kids can
pick up new languages you can't teach an
old dog new tricks etc my interpretation
of that though is that children their
brains are so
classic and so malleable because they're
learning so much if you think what it's
like to be a child everything is new
everything is fresh they're learning to
use their sensors for the first time
they're learning to walk and move around
you know every single thing is a lesson
they learn to interact with supports
everything is new it's all new stimuli
and the brain has to learn in order to
survive it has to learn fast and a lot
and so this is what causes the brain to
become more plastic and as you learn
there's less new stuff to learn and so
you begin to settle and produce fewer of
those chemicals the brain becomes less
plastic but it's nothing special about
the child's brain it's just the fact
that they are subject to so many new
things and studies show that even later
on in adulthood when you're learning
these subjects exposed to novel stimuli
you do produce more of those neuro
chemicals like the B D and s so imagine
if you could surround yourself with that
much novel stimuli your brain would
become so plastic and then you could
train to do pretty much anything and
learn it super fast now of course we're
never going to be able to retrace those
circumstances we just have learned too
much we know too much but what we can do
is keep learning keep trying new things
maybe one day virtual reality will allow
us to you know immerse ourselves with
completely alien worlds but until then
we can just keep learning keep taking on
new challenges keep exposing ourselves
to new experiences new environments and
as we do this our brain will produce
more of those chemicals a brain will
become more plastic and the more we
learn the more we use it the more we'll
be able to learn more and the more we'll
be able to pick up new skills so if you
practice learning lots of things
exploding itself new things especially
learning new physical skills the brain
loves movement your brain will become
more washing those chemicals more
malleable and you can practice those
things I spoke about earlier
visualization training ambidexterity etc
and perhaps your brain will become a
little more like Einstein and you will
learn to think a bit more like Feinstein
but I'm not even saying that that's
something you'd want to do short I'm
showing pretty genius but who's to say
that math and spatial awareness are more
valuable than other types of
intelligence what you need to do is not
become more like Einstein but become
more like you just
best version of you there are quite
nonsense Ram even by my standards most
people aren't going to go off and train
their brain to be more like Einsteins
but I hope you found it interesting and
useful and maybe there's some nugget
there you can apply to Reina life is
certainly interesting to think about the
different kinds of intelligence and how
that is reflected by different
structures in the brain and how we can
maybe change those structures to change
the way we think if you did find it
useful or interesting then please leave
a like down below it helps me great
deals maybe share the video with people
leave a comment down below so got any
questions or suggestions because I'd
love to hear them I try and answer as
many as I can check out the blog where
I've plugged many of my related posts or
the other videos and yes they tuned for
more on the way more brain training
neuroscience and trade picks
bodybuilding fitness productivity
technology etc if that sounds good then
I'll see you in the next one thanks very
much for watching and bye for now